40% of Americans are afraid to walk
alone at night most in decades this is a
Miami Herald story let's see what this
is the herald so all right so concerns
about certain crimes in the US are at
the highest levels in decades despite a
decreas in violent crime Nationwide a
gallopo found that 28% Americans worry
about being murdered a near high and 72%
worry about falling victim to identity
theft additionally 50% worry about their
cars being stolen or broken into 37%
fear being mugged and 32% are concerned
about being attacked while driving the
heightened fear has led to a significant
impact on daily life with 40% Americans
being afraid to walk alone at night
within a mile of their home the highest
number in three decades crime concerns
also prevent 34% from driving in certain
areas 28% from attending events and 28%
from speaking to strangers does any of
this apply to you uh are you concerned I
mean p Pat you know me I'm I I love
living in Florida cuz I'm armed all the
time but what what do you expect Pat
when you have not only the open border
you uh you can steal up to whatever what
$1,000 and underneath the defund the
police attitude has made cops not give a
[__] because they don't want to why
would you want to help if you were a cop
everybody's watching you everybody's
trying to record you and see if you if
you f up I think I think people should
be concerned and you should be armed and
you should take care of yourself cuz at
the end of the day when [__] it's the
fan who's going to help you you're going
to stop and like hold on one second let
me call 911 to a cop that can give two
shits now because the country's been
[__] on them for the past five years
no it's you have to protect yourself and
I'm I don't I good good guys be be
worried and be scared with an open
border with the sentiment that we've had
towards cops with with uh States saying
you know what steal as much as you want
who gives us just long as it's they're
incentivizing people to steal and [__]
yes I I think everybody should be
worried and you should be armed you
should take care of yourself cuz
nobody's going to help you yeah I'm
increasingly concerned about personal
security but I don't let it affect you
know that I'm too scared to go outside
or not do things in life you know I
still go to football games I still go
out and shop I still do things but I'm
hyper aware and with a a daughter who's
about to go off to college in you know
nine months from now she's going to be
going off to college we talk about uh
personal protection we talk about you
know the things you do when you get out
of a car in a parking lot you know
looking around and it's just there's
there's more train and more awareness
and more just being because if you if
you do these things and I set her up
with a license so she can get pepper
spray and all that kind of stuff if you
do all that then you can live more
comfortably and and not just be scared
looking over your shoulder I would hate
to live a life where I was just scared
looking over my shoulder every day I
want to feel perfectly comfortable and
unconcerned going to the ATM going to
the store going to the beach going to a
football game but you know what but you
know I've got precautions I've you know
I've you know you can get a carry permit
you can get your children set up at the
right age you know to be trained in use
of pepper spray and things and so you
you have plan B why do you have a fire
extinguisher in a a kitchen just in case
but you don't worry about every day I
hope there's not a fire I hope there's
not a fire but you have what you need
when you need it that's how I want to
live life is live life not you know
stupid and unassuming and walk into to
something and I should have been looking
around and paying attention but I want
to live life comfortably with freedom
and and have a a degree of U just peace
about myself when I go out but I will
have fire extinguishers well I'll tell
you what these stats uh they're alarming
and they're just quite frankly sad so
the the 28% of Americans feel worried
about being murdered okay 72% fall
victim identity that 50% worried about
their cars 37 being mugged 32% being
attacked while driving it's it's absurd
so this just sort of gives Credence to
the American first ideology it's like
we're trying to be a policemen of the
world and in some instances we should
because if if America takes a a step
back who then leads the world China
Russia Iran the axes of evil hell no but
at the same time we do need to take care
of America we see these open border
policy basically ruining America
something that wasn't an issue until
Trump made an issue but it was obviously
the news perpetuated the racist wall and
all that now we're looking back at it
and Biden's like you know what if we
Build That Wall buddy you know so we see
what's going on here so um the the the
rot within America and American society
the decline American values is real It's
just sad to see and guess what gun
that's because of these stats that's why
gun sales are at an alltime High people
aren't being by the way they're every
year they're getting higher higher and
can I be dead serious with you when you
are armed P legally armed and protected
I don't feel as scared because I know
that I'm going to take care of myself if
[__] does hit the fan that's why I roll
with Vinnie as my by way do you know do
you know what percentage of Iranians own
a gun in Iran in Iran
7.3% they even get you know what
percentage of Americans own a gun 120%
let's go baby did you notice that or no
hold up what percentage of a a gun
ownership worldwide legal legal
legal some people guns divided by
population yeah yeah yeah it's it's
percentage of do they have it um broken
down by how many people actually own a
gun like I think it's like probably 25%
of Americans I don't know see what I'm
saying go right there zoom in right say
gun ownership us is
120% Serbia's 39 Uruguay is's 35
Canada's 35 finland's 32 look at number
two yeah faulin Island listen they still
don't trust the British first or last in
other words what this tells me is Rob
can you do me a favor a do you know what
the former National Security
Council you mean the guy at the food
carart oh the guy that said hide your
wife hide your kids your
husband rap everybody rap everybody play
this clip it's by far the best one if I
just texted it to you uh and then go to
a minute five I mean this thing was so
popular that it became a rap song you
don't want to have you seen a yes
amazing clip Swan doson turns into a rap
song oh yeah cuz they ring everybody up
in here yeah yeah just go to minute five
there's certain there 10 years ago this
was you couldn't escap this this is a
the equivalent of the big black guy with
the uh black bar certain hits certain
hits are good to minute five oh and the
picture of the leprechaun yeah right
right was that part of it watch this
obviously we have a rapist in Lincoln
Park he's climbing in your windows he's
snatching your people up trying to so
y'all need to hi your kids hi your wife
and had your H because they raping
everybody out the attacker got loose and
went out if this is the SK by the way is
this the sketch see if there's a picture
of the guy was that part of this by the
way no no keep pressing play without the
ball said and your husbands cuz they
raping everybody
get oh don't turn out the audio let us
listen to good he go you I think they
had a sketch that fingerprints and all
you are so dumb you are really dumb for
real a crime scene investigator
photographed and dusted for prints on
the lid of the garbage can in the window
pain and ledge Dodson says he's never
seen the per before but sends this
warning to whoever is responsible you
don't have to come and confess that you
did we're looking for you we we going to
find you I'm letting you know n so you
can run and tell that on boy home boy
yeah anine doson for president oh bro
can you imagine he had no while he was
doing that he was going to go viral we
raping everybody up by the way that was
over 10 years ago I want to say that was
under the Obama Administration years ago
is he doing speeches now so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here